Act now for this limited time
offer.
>> IS THE WHITE HOUSE
INSTRUCTING BORDER AGENTS TO
REFUSE RIDE ALONG REQUESTS FROM
REPORTERS?
>> THAT’S CREATED THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
>> IF YOU WANTED TO GRANT ACCESS
TO THE PRESS, COULDN’T YOU JUST
TELL DHS TO DO IT?
>> Secretary Psaki: I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TALK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
FOR ANY REQUEST FOR PRESS ACCESS
OR FOR WHAT YOU’RE LOOKING TO
ACCOMPLISH AT THE BORDER.
>> Harris: WE ARE SMART ENOUGH
TO KNOW THAT THAT’S NOT REALLY
AN ANSWER TO THE QUESTION.
STILL, NO INDICATION FROM
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY ON
WHEN THE MEDIA MIGHT GET TO SEE
THE CONDITIONS INSIDE THOSE
OVERCROWDED BORDER FACILITIES
AND THIS SPEAR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SAID TO BE
LIMITING CONTACT BETWEEN BORDER
OFFICIALS AND THE MEDIA.
OFFICIALS SAY THEY WERE TOLD TO
DENY OPPRESSED REQUESTS FOR A
RIDE WITH AGENTS.
AND FORWARD ANY INQUIRIES TO THE
D.C. PRESS OFFICE FOR APPROVAL.
JOE CONCHA IS A MEDIA AND
POLITICS COLUMNIST FOR THE HILL
AND A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
FIRST OF ALL, JUST YOUR REACTION
TO THAT AND CAN WE WORK AROUND
THAT TO GET SOME FACTS?
>> ONE WOULD THINK.
I ALWAYS HEARD THIS SAYING THAT
THE BUCK STOPS HERE WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE.
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE BREAKS EVERY
THEORY TO SAY GO TALK TO DHS, WE
CAN HANDLE THAT.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE ONE OF THE MOST HONEST AND
TRANSPARENT ADMINISTRATIONS THAT
WE WILL SEE.
INSTEAD WE SEE A MEDIA BLACKOUT
AT THE BORDER.
IMAGINE IF PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD
DONE THIS.
THEY WERE ITS AUTHORITARIAN AND
DICTATOR, THE QUOTA WOULD RUN
OUT.
WE KNOW WHY THERE’S A BLACKOUT.
YOU HAVE FACILITIES THAT ARE AT
100% BEING OVERRUN.
THE CDC SAYS THESE FACILITIES
HAVE 50% BECAUSE I WAS COVID AND
NOW THEY ARE AT 100% PURITY OF
MIGRANTS BY THE HUNDREDS TESTING
POSITIVE FOR COVID AND BEING
RELEASED INTO THE U.S.
POPULATION THAT IS LITERALLY A
SUPERS BREADED EVENT.
AND CERTAINLY SOMETHING YOU
SUPPORT.
OKAY.
IF IT’S SOMETHING THEY SUPPORT,
TO SIMPLY SAY, ALLOW THE MEDIA
IN AND SEE WHAT’S GOING ON.
BUT INSTEAD, IT’S THE USUAL
DODGE.
>> Harris: THERE IS LAYERING
ON TO THIS.
AS JOURNALISTS, THIS IS REALLY A
PROBLEM.
WHEN YOU START TO TELL THE VERY
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THE WORK OF
THIS THAT THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO TALK TO THE PRESS, WHAT IS
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES?
IS THERE A THREAT THEY ARE TO
THEIR JOB?
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
THE FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT
INFORMATION.
IF THEY WANT TO TALK AND PUT IN
WRITING, WE CAN DO THAT.
WHAT DOES THIS ADMINISTRATION
TRYING TO SAY?
IS THIS A HIT ON US AS REPORTERS
REPORTERS?
>> IT CERTAINLY SEEMS THAT WAY.
IT’S TYPICAL OF THE PATTERN AS
FAR AS NOT ALLOWING ANY ACCESS
TO THE PRESIDENT, FOR INSTANCE
IN TERMS OF A PRESS CONFERENCE
NOT BEING HELD FOR NINE WEEKS
INTO AND ADMINISTRATION.
AT THE BORDER, THE FACT THAT --
IT’S NOT ONLY THAT HE IS PUTTING
IN REQUEST SAYING WE WANT TO SEE
THESE FACILITIES IN OTHER NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE AS WELL BE AT
THE REQUESTS AREN’T EVEN BEING
RETURNED IN THIS SITUATION.
WHILE THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS RIGHT NOW ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OVERSHADOWING
EVERYTHING.
WHEN THIS NEWS CONFERENCE COMES
UP IN NINE DAYS, GUESS WHAT’S
GONNA DICTATE THAT NEWS
CONFERENCE.
IF THEY HOLD IT RIGHT AFTER THIS
COVID BILL THAT WAS SIGNED,
MAYBE THAT WAS THE STORY OF THE
DAY.
NINE DAYS FROM NOW, 90 DAYS FROM
NOW.
IT’S ONLY GOING TO GET WHERE IT
THE WEATHER GETS WARMER.
>> Harris: I DO WANT TO THROW
WHEN THAT AT LEAST ONE OF THE
FACILITIES, IMAGE AND THEY ARE